Yo, man.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah,
yeah, yeah, yeah
is
a
office
Hello?
Can you hear me now?
Sorry.
I even...
I...
I forgot to put chat, too.
Look at me, I'm a wizard!
Oh man, my hat's kind of fucked.
I'm a wizard.
It's alright.
I'm going to be looking towards the left, anyways.
Look at me!
I'm so cute, I love this outfit.
I'm a wizard!
Okay, let me um...
Let me fix chat.
I...
What the fuck is that?
I don't know why, every time I start streaming,
I get my...
a virtual camera on OBS starts,
and I don't even know what that means.
Um...
Sorry, one second!
Let me put in chat.
Oh, wrong button.
Oh no, wait, no, that was the right button.
Thank you for becoming a member, uh...
Daniel?
Life chat?
Uh...
How do I pop out again?
Pop out.
There we go!
Hi!
Welcome to today's um...
Wizard101 stream!
How are you?
I'm eating.
Thank you for becoming a member,
Crack.
Hope you had fun at the beach.
Can't believe you're 30 and a wizard.
30?
What do you mean 30? I'm not 30?
Something wrong?
I'm not 30, what do you mean 30?
Huh?
Dirty 30? She doesn't know the lore?
Haglev?
What do you mean?
There's a saying that being 30
and a virgin makes you a wizard.
Oh!
I've never heard of that saying!
I've never heard of it.
Oh! I've never heard of that saying!
I've never heard of that saying before.
What the fuck?
Okay.
Um...
I'm eating um...
rice and pot stickers.
Now, before I um...
Before I start the game,
we're supposed to make our schedules
for the next week on...
Oops.
Oh no, I don't remember my password.
Why am I like this?
We're supposed to make our schedules
for next week on Wednesdays?
Like for the next week on Wednesdays?
Oh fuck, I don't remember my fucking password.
And I was gonna make the schedule with you.
If I remembered my password!
Um...
What?
Hold on, hold on.
I can get it, I can get it.
Give me a second.
Login is temporarily disabled
for this account because of numerous failed login attempts.
Please try again in a minute.
I swear...
that I...
I don't know how to turn that up.
I swear I knew the password.
Damn it.
Okay, well I'll try again in a minute.
How have you been?
Do you mind if I eat loud?
I'm a loud chewer.
You didn't write stuff down?
Are you gay?
Let me check in my notes if I wrote it down anywhere.
Thank you for the ten dollars, but...
I just went to the beach for two days.
If I didn't even tell you,
I went to the beach you wouldn't have known.
Or was it...
Did I say two dollars instead of ten?
Oh, I did write my password.
Oh!
I'm so smart.
I wrote down my password in my notes app.
Okay, hold on, I got this.
Okay.
Email or password is not valid!
But it's valid!
Maybe I'll wait a little longer.
I'll wait a little longer.
How was the beach? Did you get a tan? No.
Not really.
I wore sunscreen and then the second day,
they didn't really have...
They didn't really have that much sun.
Like, the beach didn't have much sun the second day.
Well, I don't like being tanned anyways,
so like...
I wouldn't have let myself get tanned.
It doesn't matter.
I would not let myself get tanned.
But it was nice.
I had fun.
Made a little sand castle.
The food was kind of shit though.
I'm not gonna lie.
Like...
For some reason,
the days that I went to the beach
were the days that everything was closed.
Because it's like a tourist area.
So they're always open on like the weekends and shit.
But...
Not really on like Mondays and Tuesdays
and I was so fucking pissed because I couldn't go
to any places because they were all closed
on Mondays and Tuesdays.
So I couldn't really do much.
Okay, let's try this again.
I know, how dare they be fucking closed.
I locked in! Let's go!
Yes, please save that password.
Okay, so...
We're gonna make my schedule for next week together.
And I guess you'll know my schedule right now.
You'll know my schedule right now.
So...
I'm able to stream on Mondays now
because
my piano lessons moved to a different day.
And a different time.
Seems like a weird business strategy.
Well, I guess just no one goes
at the start of the week.
You know?
Do we get to pick some streams?
Yeah, that's why I'm doing it with you.
There is one stream you don't get to pick though.
And that's the first one.
The second one is...
Is that the usual time?
I can't show you my screen
because then you'll see everyone else's schedules.
And...
Obviously, I don't want to show that
in case they don't want to show that.
But on Monday,
we're gonna play...
Fuck, what's the game?
Let me look up the game, hold on.
Is it this?
On Monday, we're playing Chains Together
with a...
with a few fun, cute
girlies with Shibi.
Hold on, let me look up the names.
The full names of the rest.
Because I need to put in the full names.
Uh...
Um...
Utahime Mochizuki
from Special Light.
Um...
And...
One more girl from Special Light.
Victoria Valerie
from Special Light.
Now, this isn't completely concrete, but...
I think it's mostly concrete.
So, yeah.
We're playing Chains Together on Monday.
Now, the rest of the days, I...
don't know what to do.
Yeah.
Hope you don't...
mauled too much. I don't think I will.
I don't think I will.
Let's do Imi's homework.
Um...
No, I still have piano lessons.
Not on that day, that's all.
That's all.
I got to see a little of Imi's Construction Company.
Did you make it alone? I did.
I did make it alone.
ASMR the rest of the week.
I can't do ASMR all week.
I can do it one day of the week.
Do you have membership?
Um...
I would like to have a membership stream next week.
Okay, you want one ASMR?
Okay. Do you want it to be members only,
or do you want it to be public?
I don't know.
I kind of stay away from watch-alongs.
Just because I feel like
they're not that entertaining.
Is that mean maybe?
If you have the membership on...
Oh!
Wizard 101.
I don't.
But if we get paywalled,
then I might buy it. We'll see.
You sound sick.
I'm okay.
I'm just not always like...
super um...
hyper.
Sometimes I'm chill.
Surprisingly, sometimes I'm chill.
We want watch-along?
I kind of hate watch-alongs.
You sound normal.
Is this nipples?
Oh! Yeah, I always sniffle.
I always sniffle. I'm a sniffly girl.
Minecraft would be fun, karaoke would be fun.
Members only for ASMR?
Alright, we'll do a member ASMR
on...
Wednesday then.
Is that okay?
You shouldn't get paywalled this stream, to be honest.
I hope not.
After Triton Avenue?
Everything passed that requires crowns or membership.
That's so shitty. I do remember getting paywalled
as a kid. I do remember that.
Okay, I'm gonna do...
I'm gonna do um...
ASMR stream
on Wednesday.
I never put
like what the...
um...
what the like...
um... theme of the ASMR
ASMR is because I actually don't know
until like the day of
or maybe like a little later.
You should do another karaoke.
I don't think I will yet.
I don't think I'm ready
for another karaoke
mentally.
I saw Minecraft though.
Did you do the 30k stream yet?
Wait, did I...
Did I have some goal
for 30k stream?
Well, thank you for the membership
fund.
Membership is $5.
That's not too bad.
As a kid, it was bad though.
As a kid, it was bad.
Oh, apartment tour!
Oh...
fit.
Okay.
You want that?
You really want that?
Okay, sure. We can do an apartment tour here.
I'll put an apartment tour on Friday.
30k celebration stream
apartment
tour.
That's going to be on Friday
at the usual time.
And then I'd like to do...
I'd like to do one more on Sunday.
So...
Um...
I guess since a lot of people
are liking Minecraft, we could do something in Minecraft.
I thought Brosly was Friday?
This is for next week.
No.
Brosly isn't going to be every Friday.
It's just this Friday.
Today's Wednesday, right?
Am I going crazy?
Piano playing?
You want a piano playing stream?
Stop gaslighting me!
I know it's Wednesday!
Okay, well...
I'll do...
Thank you for the $5.
I can look it up.
There was one game I wanted to play.
Oh my god, it looks exactly like Minecraft.
Wait, what the fuck?
It's just Minecraft.
Wait, it just looks like a Minecraft
rip-off.
Oh my god.
It does look cute though.
I'll put a pool.
Also, thank you for 37k.
Um...
That short kind of...
Excuse me.
That short kind of pushed me
to 37k.
Oh, more of a mod that became its own thing.
Ah, I see.
Okay, oops, that's not a cue.
Pull, pull, pull.
What do you want
for next week?
Next week.
Minecraft...
or piano streaming.
There.
Little nightmares?
We could play little nightmares too, maybe.
I don't know.
What are you eating?
I'm eating pot stickers and rice.
So,
the vintage story was directly inspired
by Terraform Craft?
Eww...
I don't know what Terraform Craft is.
I'm guessing that's a mod in Minecraft.
I don't know what the goal for 40k is.
I don't know if I'll have a goal for 40k!
Okay, it seems like most people are saying, um, piano stream, so I'll make it a piano
stream then don't don't don't have high expectations okay I'm not Mozart I'm not
even Mozart's fart okay I'm truly like a beginner also it's not gonna be hand cam
it's just gonna be like the model and I probably won't take requests because unless
they're like super super simple then I might take requests I know we'll see okay
drunk IRL painting we already painted IRL I don't know I don't feel like that's like a
you know we already did that basically for fun it's okay to skip 40k and do something special
for 50k
how far you've come by like next year do you mean subs wise or piano wise
can you play hot cross buns I think I could isn't hot cross buns like super easy
I think that's like a beginner game right I'm not game but like bingy um song
I really need to turn that up before I forget also I have a fun fun not a fun story but like
an interesting story that I never really talked about I hope um live streamers
hold on I just want to turn up one of the notifications sounds real quick but I'll
tell you the story while I do it um except alerts is it alerts
oh thank you for the 20 gifted oh my god thank you thirdity
oh now I have to mute the alerts um I think it's the members that though that goes
yeah Pikmin sound effect I'm gonna make it louder there safe watch it like earblast you now
thank you for the 20 gifted yeah maybe I can play like twinkle twinkle little stars like something
easy like that yeah I can't give you like really big rewards for milestones because I still haven't
done the 10k milestone so I feel bad being like oh I'll do this huge thing for 50 or 40k because
it's like I haven't even finished the 10k milestone so yeah
you should really figure out how to remove those alerts at some point wait which alerts
like the one at a time thing I thought that was normal I thought that's just how it was is it
not normal do other streamers not have like the one at a time alert for gifted memberships
what was for 10k it was um ducky art it was doc ducky art
oh there we go use microphone wait why is it my microphone
my microphone isn't connected to vtube studio for some reason
I was wondering why my mouth tracking was kind of off
hello okay there we go oh man
uh it doesn't recognize the microphone oh well you're gonna have kind of off mouth tracking
um other streamers typically just have one alert for x gifted 20 subs I don't know why they're
showing up one by one oh 50k was hex code was it was it actually
can I go back on that can I go back on that
okay hold on let me try reloading vtube studio real quick
oh no Amy's gone she's gone she left us she's gone forever I forgot to tell you the story that
I was gonna tell you too um coming back don't worry the meds are wearing off
the skit so meds are working she's gone
there we go there there's my microphone there we go that's better right tell me it's better
tell me I didn't do all that for nothing
oh
okay
why is my shirt
my nips we're almost out
my nips we're almost out okay
okay
I used the vanishing potion yet so um what was I talking about right so
I don't know how deep I can go into this but I won't go too deep in it basically um
Uta DM'd me on Twitter right and when I saw her DM I like stalked her a little bit because
that's what I do like if if you DM me on Twitter I'm gonna stalk you um if you're a vtuber that is
right and I listened to her and I was like hmm her voice sounds familiar I feel like I've
heard that voice before right and so I did a little deep diving I did a little interrogating
from Uta and I found out that Uta was like okay I don't want to call her like an oh she because
I didn't really know what oh she's were back then but I watched Uta like
like years ago like years and years ago before I was even a vtuber before I really knew exactly
what vtubers were um I watched Uta like a long time ago and I was like holy crap
I kind of failed fan girl because I thought she was really cool
and now I get to collab with her
I get to collab with her now
I was like oh my god Uta I love your song cover
and she was like those song covers no those are bad well I don't know if she said those
can you fucking chew your food before you talk I know she said they were bad but she was like
you like those old song covers and I was like yes yes
so that was cool oh she is what how are you watching my stream and you don't know what
oh she is it's just like it's just like your favorite vtuber I guess I guess that's basically
what it is yeah that's the story I don't know I thought it was cool and what's crazy is she
remembered me she remembered me and I was fan girling so hard okay um we're done with the
schedule let me open um wizard 101 now I do ask that you don't play with me it sounds mean
but I like to play alone um I'm okay with you like oh fuck what was my password I'm okay with
you back seating me like in chat being like oh Amy you should play this spell like you should do
this but like that's fine with me but I don't like to be like follow it around in game I don't like to
be like gifted stuff in game um I just want to play by myself so yeah I'm gonna I'm gonna I'm a lone wolf
so yeah
you're enough of a niche internet microcelebrity to be noticed
I guess I am I guess ah what happened to me
oh fuck okay let's just oh shit oh fuck what's happening oh okay okay wow that's really loud okay
hold on let me let's let's get to the game
oh chat's broken
aha the spell is working hold on
um
I need to turn the volume lower oh what the fuck
um guys can you see the game oh there we go no oh oh what oh I'm getting a lot of issues right now
okay
um if I click on the game it's gonna move me okay uh
yeah it does that why does it do that okay hold on let me see if I can off full screen off
okay
what
full screen off what oh I'm not good with resolutions this one
what is this resolution I hate wizards 101 I officially hate this game
oh that's even tinier
huh
can you please be a normal resolution
what the fuck why am I getting cut off with it
okay this one
okay okay okay
okay there we go I'm getting it hold on I'm getting it sorry scuff scuff why isn't chat there what
happened to chat chat
god this music is so loud in my ear okay hold on just just just just stick with me stick with
me stick with me I'm getting there okay I'm getting there hold on hold on hold on hold on
stay with me please don't leave me
I need to get chat
okay uh pop out chat
there we go chat's back okay and then let me just turn the music down
on
okay I think we should be good now
okay um
um
I hope we're good is that okay can you hear everything
is this okay I'm sorry for this scuff I hope it's okay can you see everything
I think you can
oh yeah use code immi for game ourselves I'm actually drinking game ourselves right now
um don't forget the background music is going I don't know oh yes I want the game music I want
the game music there we go okay I think we can start now this is so exciting oh
I turned off the my background music I want I want the game background music
I don't know actually
they sent us samples so it was one of the samples flavor I think it was like dragon fruit
something like dragon fruit
okay nostalgia I know okay okay okay okay next look gamma finally we have found one
a wizard who a young wizard a student with amazing potential the graphics and this is
are so bad dragon fruit is a good one yeah it's really good I really like it I wish I
got more than samples
oh did you know that she be is on one of the she's on the anime thighs flavor like her
thighs are on the around the um like on the on the tub thank you for becoming a member
her thighs are on the tub that's so cool
it's insane I know right
she's on there with some good company I know she's on there with like really popular
other anime girl thighs
perhaps we should consult the book of secrets headmaster ambrose terms to regard you intently
answer these questions to find out oh yeah I remember this oh my god
I don't know if I'll ever get a flavor um
I don't think so I don't think so but I'm okay with that I'm okay with that
yeah
smack away okay I'll continue um when I complete oh when I compete my goal is to win
a trophy for my team oh I remember these I remember these which of these is the most
powerful hurricane tornado sandstorm volcano earthquake blizzard plague
um I think plague my favorite class in school is none of this shit I hate all of it
um
reading and writing what's your favorite season
I'm gonna go with fall what is most what is more important to you competing against others
cooperating with others I don't like competing what's your favorite animal a unicorn what's
your favorite gemstone um
citrine the school of balance wow
and any pumpkin spice season flavor I don't even like pumpkin spice I don't actually like pumpkin
flavored stuff I don't know what my flavor would be maybe like
I guess it would have to be pumpkin wouldn't it
would you like a mint flavored one or is that gross to you
you
apple cinnamon that sounds good I like cinnamon drinks
but now that we know what you are what do you look like I love designing my character
mint drinks are a little odd I know peach is an option peach is an option but I feel
like peach isn't in character for me um custom we ain't doing no preset round here
okay wow oh god man this game is so ugly oh man this game is so ugly okay um
are these girl hairstyles or is it just for everyone
well um I'll just go with that
hair color of course has to be orange oh yeah that's so ugly
maybe that looks a little better a ginger flavor complete it would completely fit and
be super yummy I've never tried ginger flavored drinks whoa look at those brows
why are they also thick oh it's the eyes too
oh wow
I can be like mega evil never had ginger ale oh well I've had ginger ale I guess I didn't really
think of that when I thought of ginger why are all the eyes so mean like why are they also
devious looking
why are they also devious looking
I'll just go with that that one looks like the nicest eyes
eye color minor pink
I look so scary oh my god
hold on I have to move my phone into my way um oh those are pretty
I look like I've I look like I've seen some things with these eyes let's just do that
eyebrow color oh pale
southern orange
wizards are mean because they're hags what no they're not I'm not a hag I'm not a hag and I
refuse to live my wizard be one either
all these faces are so woofy Jesus Christ that's terrifying
um you have to be 30 to be a wizard
why are you guys why are you why are you gatekeeping wizardry right now
anyone can be a wizard if they want
anyone could be a wizard they don't have to be 30 or a virgin if you want to be a wizard you
can be a wizard okay okay
okay left color give me some lipstick oh oh ew
oh okay noses wow look at look at the diversity here such diversity in noses
face paint oh I can be so emo and cool oh ills oh they have freckles they have freckles
you can only be a wizard if you're this tall I'll just wear heels I don't need to you
don't you can't you can't gate keep wizardry from me I want wizard glasses
what is this oh hat color oh I should match the one I'm wearing right now right so let's be emo
um the trim is like pink oh they don't really have pink orange maybe oh wait no they do no
they don't have pink um sorry I'm like really picky about um my clothes and games
oh I have green oh but that looks ugly why do I look like a man in this game
girl I look like a man because I was playing as a man
damn it damn it I was a man oh that's scary
oh she looks cool okay you know what I was wondering what's wrong
oh they even have my hairstyle you were a guy this whole time they even have my hairstyle
okay okay I won't go too hard um I won't go too crazy I'll leave most of it as it is
I'll just change the eye color there and then add the glasses because I want to look nerdy
and then change this to black
there
there we go that's me it's literally me
almost made Jimmy
if you ever wish to alter your appearance in the future simply pay a visit to the magic mirror
shop oh that's cool I didn't know you could change all right then oh damn I can't make my own name
is that a wand in your pocket or are you just happy to see me
I'm so pissed I remember you can't talk in chat either right
you can't talk in chat it's like because it's for kids right
I think that's that was that was the thing
um okay well let's let's find an eye name
is isabella oh Imani is pretty close to in me
you have to get your parents to say you can if you're 13 years old or older you can oh
I remember not being able to talk in chat when I was okay
okay um I'll choose Imani just because that's close to in me um
in me in me Imani enigma that's a fun name
Imani enigma stalker that's gonna be my name no you can't make your own name
can you put rat as your last name I highly doubt it
abcdfjjkl9qrs
yes I do have to say the whole alphabet to remember where art is
hello where's our runner rogue river
ray no you can't have rat as the last name
stalker there put sigma in your name I can't
Imani was based in playing wizards 101 I am based I'm a based wizards 101 enjoyer
I actually don't know if I'll like the game or not I played through the
tutorial like 10 fucking times why do I have a virtual camera what is that
I'm always so I don't know how to use obs but for some reason my virtual camera keeps starting on obs
our newest student okay um I'll play the tutorial just because I don't know how to play the game anymore
I am the headmaster the school of magical arts I finished my food so I'm just gonna
I still have a bunch of race on my plate but I'm just gonna put it on my bed
no I don't know I don't even know what a virtual camera does I don't have my webcam connected
to my computer right now so there's nothing to really see
crazy how much MMOs look exactly like world of warcraft at this time does this look like
world of warcraft I've never actually played world of warcraft
I move around use the arrow my old friend would like to speak with you
walk up to gamma and follow his instructions to talk
it's too sensitive oh no no no no okay well
hello my name is gamma the owl and I am quite pleased it looks a lot like world of warcraft
really maybe I should play world of warcraft I like the style of this I think it's really cute
I like how old oldy like old oldy I like how old it looks it's cute old kind of ugly but
it's just world of warcraft but brighter no see that's what I need I need my games to be bright
I don't like dark ugly games I feel like every RPG game these days are just like
ugly and dark like give me give me mystical wonder give me give me magical pretty sparkly
forests you know like I want to see magical things I want to see pink trees I want to see like
giant dragon castles like with fairies and like really pretty cool animals like give me like
ginormous deer that like I don't know how have leaves growing out of their back and
shit you know I need bright lit pretty pretty stuff to look at that that looks magical is that
so much to ask but because I feel like these days I can't find games like that Zelda's kind of like
that but yeah like where's the whimsy exactly where is the whimsy in games these days everything is
so dark and depressing should I try final fantasy I remember looking at final fantasy and it still
looked really dark just saw one of your youtube shorts and saw your life hello you're super cute
thank you I'm surprised people came from shorts um I might I have a lot to say about that short
I'm sure other people have a lot to say about the short too but I'll talk about it first because
it's my short and I made it and it's kind of my fault but basically um so the comments on that
short that I'm getting on on Twitter it's been the most I haven't really checked the
comments on Twitter that much but I feel like on Twitter they've been the most respectful
but holy shit the comments I've gotten on tiktok and youtube shorts have been such a slap
to the face I've been just bombarded with the most backhanded compliments every single not every
single but like half the comments I have to just straight up delete or mute them from my channel
because they're the most backhanded rude compliments like everyone's like not everyone but like I've
gotten so many comments saying like why do vtubers even put on a voice like you sound like so annoying
with your high-pitched voice like why don't you just use your natural voice and it's so annoying
I've had to mute my comment section on tiktok because I I I just I couldn't do it anymore
and I know that I kind of it's kind of my fault because I um the way I kind of set up that the
short was very um it was kind of aimed more towards people who don't really know much about vtubers
you know I wanted to explain the the vtuber community to them I guess but I I don't know why
but tiktok just shows my content to people who dislike vtubers so yeah a lot of my comments are
just like why why do you talk like that like you're and I I'm happy that I'm receiving compliments
for my natural voice but it's also like you don't have to make the compliment backhanded you know
and I usually like tiktok I've actually never received hate on tiktok up until um very recently
like I always got basically nothing but support even with this voice even posting with this voice
I I've never received hate for it up until recently so I was just really confused um yeah there's no
reason to insult like it's fine if you like my natural voice but you don't have to shit on this
one you can just say oh wow your your natural voice is so hot like I've got a lot of comments
like that too and I really appreciate them but a lot of them are like wow your natural voice is so
hot and your cute voice is so annoying and it's like oh thanks I guess I just wanted to rant about
because it's been like on my mind um this whole time call me a fool so I had all but forgotten yeah
algorithm cum is drunk again and sending your shorts to aunties on tiktok kind of on tiktok yeah
a little bit yeah I'm trying to educate the normies but I think I think because I'm a loli
they kind of hate me so anytime they see me they kind of just use my short to hate on youtubers
in general so yeah but I'm happy that the people that watch me are supportive because I got a lot
of comments saying like oh if you talked in a natural voice I would actually watch your streams
and then I would check their profile and they're not even following me and it's like
no you wouldn't why should I change for you you you're not following me you're not watching me
like yeah I got a lot of comments like that a lot and that really annoyed me too um but yeah sorry for the
rant um sorry for the read but I just wanted to know about it you're in trouble quickly use the
you I haven't even been able to do this cast it on yourself it will replenish I'd watch you
regardless of which voice you use thank you see that's what I really appreciate me I have comments
like that too like oh both are nice and that's that's what I appreciate the most um
yeah you being a lolly weeds up all the anties and you want to end up getting hate later done the
line from fans it does weed them out but they're still like commenting on my stuff about it like
yeah they don't watch my streams of course but they're like gross and I don't think they let you die
in this do they I never understood hate comments like if you don't agree or like something just
don't watch it it's not necessarily hate most of it is just backhanded compliments that's most of it
and also a lot of comparisons to uh
is this stuffy is that hurting I forgot quickly now pick another spell and cast it at one of them
it's not the right
hate is still hate is still hate now they don't really die good
yeah snuffie a lot of comparisons to snuffie and a lot of oh you should do what snuffie did
which is you know change and sound all mommy because people love mommies and I love mommies too
but I am not a mommy I don't mind being called mommy but it's like I don't know get your head
checked not mommy yes I know that the graphics um got revamped I do know that I remember that
uh they comment because they want you to disappear I will disappear
well I'll leave what the mommy voice would be weird I know and very little people acknowledge that too
like some people were like oh I understand that it wouldn't fit the character but I still want
you to do it and it's like okay but you're not a viewer so why would I you're not you're not a viewer
do you want to be mommy no I don't really care it's not what is this
um it's not something I'm like oh yeah call me mommy it's like I don't I don't really care
you're my sister wait no matter what yes you're older younger mommy
it's the same lollies with big boobs booba it's like uncanny valley like what the
fuck I agree I'm I don't I personally am not a fan of lollies with big boobs now obviously
I'm not gonna shit on any lollies with big boobs but I um same thing with chibi characters
I think they should remain flat they should remain flat you're the peak of hotness to us
and that's what matters
deathmore an on edge type energy shondo's deep voice kind of peak though I've heard shondo shondo's
better than me she sounds way more mommy than me when she tries to
I
cute noises me not really too uncanny valley as long as the proportions are too top heavy I've
seen some crazy top heavy ones which is fine like do whatever you want um but I wouldn't personally
design a character like that because it's like you know what I like I like them flat the point
is that they're flat you know
look at me dancing I won you look a bit the worst for where I am the worst for where at all
it's honestly funnier when you rage at games since it's so shrill
thank you thank you on the bright side congratulations
defeating malice I'm happy you like it when I rage you some experience
I'm emailing on my enemies this experience bar will help you check your progress thank you
when the bar fills up you'll gain a level and be able to learn new skills dancing on their dead bodies
all boobas good flat is nice big is nice each has their own appeal that's true too that's true too
do you have any questions young wizard no you don't know how to speak well then let me teach
you how to use menu chat and we'll see what you have to say to me made an outfit check I want to
see the cute dork clothes um there's there's not much to see this is the outfit that's it this is
all that there is I just put on the dress that's all I don't have anything more than this
outfit check fit check
menu chat this is the menu chat button click on it to say something see how do I say something
like I can't hi you have the way of it now you can chat with anyone you meet and make lots of friends
here asked for an adult then she comes over and spoke in the delivery guy was thrown through a loop
what shondo's natural voice sounds like a loli which has been jarring for people who interact with her
like she told the story of how anise of hers or something answered the door for a package
they asked for an adult and then she comes over and spoke with the delivery guy was thrown through a
loop oh I don't know what shondo naturally sounds like I've never heard of it
um but I'm not I'm not a big shondo watcher but I now I understand why a lot of female
vtubers aren't honest about voice acting now I understand why they're not honest about it
I never got hate for it before but now I do and it's like damn maybe I shouldn't have been honest
I try to be honest though
I tried to be honest um but now I understand why some people aren't honest
you get shit on it for it shit on it for it shitted on them yeah I just shitted on them
you're enrollment she sounds like shondo
so if you don't mind waiting for a moment or two I'll pop back to my office and straight
I'll summon you when things are presentable can you see him or should I make him louder
I'll see him can you hear him
oh sorry let me open my stream element
new to vtuber content can you explain why vtubers need to join these groups like veeler um
thank you for the don't know um
um so they don't need to um there's vtuber groups which are usually just friend groups that they
you know have a name for their friend group and they just call it a vtuber group um
but then there's also uh vtuber like agencies um and
you don't need to join it oh what the fuck
oh there we go there we go you don't need to join one but you can if you want to
that's all there's a lot of indie people that aren't part of agencies it's just up to you
if you want to audition for one um some of them provide perks some of them claim to provide perks
and then they don't um so so watch out because um not all of them are good wink wink wink
i'm not talking about veeler um um everyone has different reasons for joining an agency so
it's really some of them are like oh i want a bigger audience so i'm going to join an agency
to try to get a bigger audience um some people are like oh i have no money and maybe an agency
will help fund you know my song covers and um idol activities concerts i don't know what do we do
and stuff like that um we really love you being honest with us i hope so
i hope you do maybe i'll stop being stop the virtual camera why does it keep putting a
virtual camera i'm gonna freak do i have the virtual camera linked to a
do i have it linked to some sort of hot key that i keep pressing what is the virtual camera
hot keys
i don't have a link to any sort of virtual i mean any sort of hot key
what the frikety frack
cool of the day what do vtubers do honestly i don't fucking know
i'm playing wizards 101 though i'm playing wizards 101
avoid the rainbows wink wink the rainbows
wait who's the rainbows
are you talking about like maybe miji janji
do i hear in me song covers yeah they're not good though i will make a huge disclaimer in the
um description that i'm i'm here for fun
virtual cameras youtube studio
it didn't start
i don't know
niji johnny john niji jonathan nijanji
strutty this one's defective what do you mean
you need to find the groups that are not a scam which is harder than one would imagine
real and true
he has something important to tell you go speak with him go speak with him
okay yay we're actually in the game now um
i don't know does the game it doesn't look blurry at all does it
i don't know
sometimes my computer gets a little blurry with games
when is the cover with kai foo coming out i don't know i have to i have to ask kai foo when
she wants to put it out oh i talked to this dude what's that you say the headmaster sent you
to help us will then you're just the person or wizard i've been waiting for
this used to be a pleasant street but we've been invited by hordes of strange creatures
we appreciate the honesty and your voice hit me like a hammer and stood marceline from
adventure time energy i saw people say that i was really surprised i don't think i sound like
marceline i wish i did uh marceline has such a pretty singing voice she's so cool i love marceline
they're undead
maybe your fancy wizard man this is what the average british man looks like past 26
i don't want to shit on british people i have british friends but it's true run up to them on the
street run up to them on the street get close enough to them they will summon a combat schedule
and you will be pulled into combat if you want to avoid battle you can keep safe by staying on the
sidewalk okay you can drive away some of these lost souls will be in your debt okay
okay i have to drive away the lost souls why'd he say wizard like a wizard's not people i don't
do they not like wizards in this world
if you don't want randos to join click those two black balls in the escape menu and join a realm
that is not populated but then you're gonna see what realm i join did you already see what realm i'm
in they're wizard phobic i don't
okay how do i talk in chat i want to say something in chat
do you check the wizard 101 forums hide the screen
huh but you don't see anything do you
do you
just i didn't see around just cover up the screen when you join a different realm oh
well if no one saw my realm it's okay waiting for more months with you to come oh thank you for
the membership here say heresy don't slurr chat i wasn't going to i just wanted to say something
i just wanted to say something
i don't know how to talk in chat
whatever i guess i'll go fight these ones
i just walked up to them
press enter
says a slurr
dude what
are you still doing marshmallow i mean yeah i'm they're still open i still read them
says his band we why why i
i can't say hi with with three eyes
what gay why are you acting so gay
thank you for the two dollars so cool to see you playing this game thank you
you can only say approved words
which words are approved in this bug but oh the red words are not approved in this game
bra i can't say bra i can't say bra come on even the kids know what bra means okay
i have to protect the kids freak the kids should i join on this person
i won't what is this what is what is this okay whatever um i want to fight by myself
should i not i shouldn't fight more than one here that one over there's
are any of these alone i don't want to fight too
come on guys why are you all together just one i just want one of you
don't fuck the kids that's not what i meant you oh man i got two of them oh no i only got one okay
oh shit this is okay wait i don't uh fucking what works against ghosts
back in the day people used to say so
okay that's bad that's so funny oh my god oh victory i have to defeat two okay you
get over here come on let's fight oh shit okay no i keep thinking there's more than one
um i'll just use the same thing because that worked really well
8 0 0 8 and 1 3 3 7 are banned wait why is 1 3 3 7 banned what does that mean
wait did that not work
all members are banned
is the music too loud i feel like it's really loud
beaten by a mere student
while your character is transparent you are safe from combat but it only lasts for a short time
1 3 3 7 is old internet talk what is it
pen 15 what is 1 3 3 7 what does that mean what does it mean
elite slang what is elite what does that mean
elite what does elite mean
lead is short for elite but what does that mean what does what do you mean by elite
are you like shitting wait talk to you talk to who
talk to con private connelly in the unit okay
elite equals best
okay but like how's why is that banned i don't get why that would be banned
this is private connelly connelly yeah
bragging it gets toxic is it like i don't know
i don't know like easy for example is it like easy like ez when you're like shitting on them
for being bad at the game
kind of oh okay
i'm gonna take my pillow off of my butt hold on
i think i already took a shower today but i may have to take another one
i didn't fart
we do need an adult wizard 101 i feel like no kids are playing wizard 101 anymore
like kids like new kids aren't playing this new kids are playing like fortnite or something you
know shower stream i don't think i can ever do a shower stream just because i i i don't have the
facet facet i don't have the facilities to um move my setup to my shower you know
i don't even have the facility to like move my setup to my kitchen like i can't
i don't have a laptop that can like stream i'm quite impressed um i don't have a laptop that
can stream so i i can't move anything before streaming yeah i think it's just the old players
my sister used to play it 10 years ago and still does now wow what a coincidence i'm your sister
and i used to play this 10 years ago too
throw an idea no i don't need a laptop it's okay
skeletal pirates would be good to know exactly what we're up against do you think you could
battle a few skeletal pirates to see how tough they are of course i can what laptop are you using
um thank you so much for doing this the laptop i used during school was an hp omen
i got it when i was in like
maybe like ninth grade and i used it all during college um and to this day i regret getting a
gaming laptop i don't know what the fuck was going through my head but that's the gaming laptop
i used to stream so maybe you know maybe it was a good thing because i probably wouldn't have been
able to stream with like a regular laptop so um but i can't i can't use it to stream anymore
it's kind of um it's kind of run its course it's a little too junky to stream nowadays
it's it i wouldn't be able to do much with it you know hp for games it was a gaming laptop it was
it was specifically advertised as a gaming laptop loving the fit thank you why do you
guys hate hp so much i'm a fan how much did you pay for it we don't talk about that we we don't
talk about that i paid more for the laptop than i did for this pc let's just say that
then you could take us to the beach i don't think the hotel wi-fi is good enough to stream
that's why i'm using a fan all hp products are trash well i didn't know that when i was in ninth
grade you think i knew anything you think i still know anything you know fight me
you think i know anything about computers no i don't know shit i know i got scammed though
i know that like i know i know gaming laptops are shit and you shouldn't get any but i did it
hp puts out a lot of terrible build quality plastic garbage well i didn't know that
hello fight me hello okay
hp is okay the omen series is budget gaming it wasn't it wasn't it wasn't budget friendly when
i bought it i don't know it had good reviews
it had good reviews
nowadays you can get good gaming laptops i don't know it was fine for a while
like it i i gained on it fine i just couldn't really stream on it it would overheat really
badly get fried that's why you build your pc listen not everyone knows how to build a pc
and not everyone has the time and energy to invest in learning how to build a pc also if you're
fucking canadian get fucked financially because any can any pc parts are is gonna cost so much
shipping to canada like holy shit hello talk to me thank you what did i learn nothing
just cross the border and bring them back yeah let me just go buy a plane ticket to
go to america to buy pc parts pirates are always creepy in a first drinking bag
i can smell my own sweat right now it smells sweaty
do you have micro centers in canada i don't even know what a micro center is
yeah can you pinpals snuggle smuggle over some pc parts for for the old me
i know it's such a shame you can't smell it
let me put my fit under my shirt real quick
monsters and mazes okay
sniffer sniffer did you like the sniffing ASMR i did i was originally gonna make that
oh i have to talk to her first i was actually originally gonna make that um dog girl ASMR
but i didn't i wasn't able to get like the the time and energy to draw a dog girl thumbnail
so i was like let me just put together a thumbnail with my model and remove any mentions of like
dog girl stuff because i mentioned some dog girl stuff um but unfortunately i couldn't incorporate
it yeah the positive affirmations one i'm glad you liked it you should do a pc building stream
no everyone's gonna shit on me no everyone's gonna shit on me and say i'm doing everything
wrong and then i got the wrong parts and then i fucked up the pc build pc i'm sorry but like
computer people are kind of insufferable sometimes i said it i said it that's it i said it that's
right you know who else is insufferable people who are always cold computer people and people who
are always cold are kind of they get on my nerves sometimes like my mom and my cousin are two people
that are always cold and they're always complaining about it and it's like damn bitch like we get it
you're skinny like i don't i don't know what to tell you like go get it go get a sweater like stop
complaining like it's literally fine everyone else here everyone else around you is fine like
okay sorry that's a really big pet peeve of mine it was really annoying with my cousin because
it's like dude it's like 32 degrees outside okay um everyone around you is wearing shorts
of course there's gonna have there's gonna be air conditioning in every building we enter because
it's hot as balls outside okay so um wear long pants and bring a sweater because i don't
know what else you expected when it's so hot outside of course every building is gonna be
air conditioned um but yeah that was a really big pet peeve of mine when i was hanging out with my
cousin like everyone else is okay just just stop complaining and and like accommodate for yourself
instead of complaining to me because what do you want me to do about it i can't do anything do you
want me to take my pants off and give them to you sorry i'm like really annoyed by this
32 celsius 32 celsius is that not hot i don't know my room is very hot too right now
oh sorry almost almost even a true ice queen knows when to let the ice melt what does that mean
cold personality or physically physically like people who are always cold physically and do
nothing but complain about it because that's what my cousin does at least my mom usually
brings a sweater and she tells me to bring a sweater even though i'm always fine who the
fuck is this morning or death bringer get out of my fight dude get out of my fight
i suck at computer building too it took me days for my first one i i i debated on making my own
i really did um i added all the parts to like uh i added all the parts to my um
um you know my shopping list and i was waiting to um save up enough money for all the parts it
was going to be like 1.6k right and so i was like cool i have all the parts in my shopping cart
so now i just need to save up enough money and then when i finally had enough money do you know
how much it costed do you know how much the price went up in a couple of months it went up to 2k
in a couple of months and i was like what am i supposed to do now what what am i supposed to
do now i i can't buy the parts anymore because it went up so so much um so i just bought a pre-built
one because it's like well i'm not gonna save up more i can't so yeah um it's the opposite it's
always too hot everywhere for me i'm usually fine everywhere i go i'm never really too hot or too
cold unless i'm outside of course because then i'm exposed to the elements but in buildings
i'm always fine um and i can always accommodate for myself like a normal person instead of
complaining all the time in asia walking around in 30-ish weather for five minutes and your shirt
yeah i'm sure it is and a lot of um like
southeast asian countries where it's like really humid
i'm always coldnessers and stuff but i just wear layers that's what i'm saying like just just wear
layers like even even if it's um because it was it was um it was summer when we were walking around
but like bring a sweater with you you know like if you're gonna complain about being cold in
every single building we go in just bring a sweater it's not that hard why is canadian
prices so crazy i don't know i don't know
um yes i'm not paying attention to her i'm just ranting
you can always just layer more clothes but you can only get so naked you know that's true
that's true pc building isn't that hard but the money involved making it intimidating scary to
put it together and not turn on for xyz reasons yeah it can be very very stressful especially
if you don't know what you're doing i'm sure you know the people who know what they're doing
are fine recommending you to build one because they know what they're doing and they're not afraid
of making mistakes but like i don't know what i'm doing what if i break apart that costed a lot of
money which is very very realistic for me to do it's very realistic for me to break apart that
costs a lot of money because i don't know what i'm doing and sure i could watch tutorials but at
the end of the day i'm i still don't know what i'm doing something always goes wrong with the
build yeah help something went wrong with my pre-built i don't have bluetooth with this computer
like i have the option for bluetooth and the bluetooth
technically works but does it actually work in practice not really like sure sure bluetooth
connects and sure i can kind of use it but it does it constantly disconnect and um constantly
like cut out yeah and i don't know why
so i can't imagine the problems i would have with a computer i built myself
you could practice on the computer you already have taking it apart and putting it
bro i'm not trying to break my pc i don't want to break this one i like this one i don't want to
break it more oh i'm supposed to kill these fairies come here come here let me fight you hello guys
guys there we go
it's the same with cars it's cost less to buy the parts and assemble it yourself than
buy a pre-built car but the ready to go car is more user friendly for non-mechanics exactly
exactly obviously maybe that's a little bit like um that comparison is a little bit
steep i don't know but
like there's a lot of learning that goes into it and it's like
i'd rather just spend more money at that point i got shit to do like playing wizards 101 you know
would you rather me not stream and try to build my own computer or would you rather me
just spend extra money and play wizards 101 with you because i'd rather play wizards 101
you should totally play more games you played as a child i love experiencing nostalgia
um i can i can whip out the emulator and fucking play mario i didn't really play that many games
as a child actually so this one i only played because my cousin introduced it to me
but like even then i didn't play this one too often because i had a poopoo laptop
that could barely handle playing this game
i have to pee how many micro transactions has wizards 101 given you yet not any yet but i
know i'll hit it eventually because i think this is a it's not a play-to-win game i mean pay-to-win
game but it's a kind of a pay-to-play game um i think i'm gonna go pee after this game
i'd love to see you play older games though yeah i don't know what older games i did play
maybe i can there is one game that i really is this turn based yes it is turn based
um okay hold on i'm gonna go pee pee
uh table cloud has been lifted okay hold on um i hope i don't get attacked be right back
so
um there's the game hi why don't you let me pee with you because I'm
embarrassed I don't want you to pee with me sorry sometimes I get a little stuck
and I go on my phone I just scrolled through my phone a little bit
okay um oh I think I turned off my audio okay there we go turned off the music
okay hello
all right I only remember what I was talking about so true that YouTube
shorts have me in a grip hold sometimes wait what are we talking about what were
you guys talking about while I was gone you could also play old games that you
haven't played before like Halo CE if you haven't I don't know if I would want to
play old games I haven't played before they're the only game I was like really
um really interested as oh this is gonna show my age hold on let me look up
this game wait look if I say that I played this game as a kid everyone's
gonna be like are you shouldn't we right now let me just look up when this game
came out um
oh man hold on let me whip up the calculator once let me just whip up the
whip out the calculator uh
no I can still say I played this as a kid I can still say right anyways there's
this um RPG game called Terra it's only available I think on the on the um on
the what on the what
it used to be available on everything but now it's only available on um console
which console is it
console version but what console do you know that game I really liked that
game no it's not it's not how I can see
opposite yeah they kind of shut it down on pc
but I really like that game and that's a game I would want to be I would want to
play with you guys you play on console or on private
servers but where can I just like you play on an emulator
I don't know ps4 and 5 can I play it on an emulator I don't want to buy a ps4
or 5 for terra I mean I might anyways but I don't want to
I wouldn't want to do that yeah it was it is still up on console um but it makes
me sad because I was a I was a I was a pewter player I was a pc player open
bone cage I'll go to lady oriel it wasn't just a select and spam keyboard
yeah the the the fighting was really cool they had really big bosses which I
really enjoyed like the game was just really fun and I really I really
liked to play the there was like they had different like um
maybe private servers but I can't download the game anymore can I
Ellen was that the race I would play as the the cute the cute girl race
with like uh animal ears I would play as that race
I heard the name somewhere in that kersh play it played it I don't know if she
did I don't know thank you for helping us kind
wizard your courage and benevolence will not okay
is she helping me is she giving is she leveling me up what is she doing
you can't launch the game on pc anymore yeah
yeah so I don't know if I can use an emulator I'm guessing I can't
let's Ellen someone modded them and and they're close to skyrim if you want to
stream it on brosley why would I stream that on brosley
what why would I do it on brosley
the rattle in the darkness okay hold on one second
to the underworld for his crimes if I focus
perhaps I can sense his location
oh it's not safe for youtube I don't really know if I would like a game like
Skyrim though Tara was really popular with vtubers early on I had no clue
when I when I was playing terror I didn't know what vtubers were
so yeah
oh I got a bro now I know kersh and peepa played it
oh the emulator would cause it to start it would get stuck at finding a
server oh okay okay
well then I can't play it on an emulator
were vtubers even a thing back then of course they were of course they were
press speed to equip the mount okay
did you play perfect world no I don't know that
Skyrim is amazing the magic kind of sucks but with mods it's a lot better
here's the thing about Skyrim it's not whimsical and pretty Skyrim is
ugly I need my games to be whimsical
and beautiful like nice cute sceneries and Tara had that Tara had really really
pretty like environments Tara was a really
really pretty game but Skyrim is ugly
I'm sorry I'm sure it's a really fun game but like
it's just not for me I don't want to feel depressed and and sad with all these
sad depressing colors you know she be
hi she be hello monkey wizard raid what
hello hello welcome thank you for raiding she be
if the elves aren't sexy it's not a good it's not good fancy
scary melts look like melted crayon people
I don't particularly care about sexy characters I just want it to be
like cute you know like I would play this game if the characters didn't look
like shit I mean honestly I would play this
game anyways um if it wasn't for kids
literally your character in game oh gee so cute I know I know
I know so adorable
Skyrim is ugly that's why my game is unrecognizable from the original
oh I'm guessing you can install like a shit ton of mods right
is that the case
uh I don't want to fight these guys I don't really like fighting
I'm also kind of bad at it but
hmm where do I go serene serene nightchant okay
the mods make Bethesda game playable I don't even know if my pc would be able
to handle mods I don't know how strong it is to be
honest okay can you use the broom oh
wait which button was for the broom again
go to your inventory and activate it
um Enchanted broom one day boo
boo fuck that that's so annoying this game did that a lot I remember it would
give you stuff for like one or two days or like a week
if you have a 1080 or higher GPU you can basically run Skyrim with as many
mods as you want that aren't high fidelity super realism graphics
I don't know what I have
I don't know what I have I'm gonna be real
oh this is the dude X
I hate rental items and games me too just give it to me man
it's a broom I'm a wizard or a witch whatever you want to call it like just
give it to me is it really gonna kill you to give me one
mount as a starting player apparently
you can buy a permanent one later on
why why do I need to purchase it it's a broom just give me one mount
one free mount is it really gonna kill you wizard 101 team
I hate that in MMM RPGs I hate it too and you know what Tara was really good
about not doing this shit from what I remember
and that's another reason why I liked it because I remember getting really cool
mounts for events and they would stay
stay with me from what I remember
do you remember the story about the recalled Harry Potter broom toy apparently
vibrated with a lot of and a lot of little girls
no I I was not actually a Harry Potter fan
um I never read Harry Potter um I know a lot of people did though
I never read a lot of popular um media or watched a lot of popular media either
they're good about it in Final Fantasy 14 too
that's good maybe I should try it I don't know I've had people tell me to try
Final Fantasy but when I looked at it I was like
this is still kind of an ugly game
um they recalled the first shipments because parents complain
I can see why they would my throw
do I have to fight these guys
break it got a lot better with don trawl now don trawl now graphics up to you
know maybe I should I don't know
if you want the game to look good it can't be an MMO why why
why is that too much to ask for should I just make my own pretty MMO
should is that what I should do do I have to do it myself at this point
oops we only do attack attack spells here
depends on the Final Fantasy game oh well give me the prettiest one
the VLR MMO the VLR MMO now with sex options for every character
it's very cute they ride around town as lalafell on a flying pig they got from
redeeming a boba tea cold but is the town cute
is the town cute I don't know how to code
I'll probably have to hire someone for me
am I gonna die
should I use here I'll use a I don't know what that does
you could play some runescape with strani I don't know how to play runescape
runescape runescape runescape I I actually don't know
anything about runescape smex MMO with immy
it's just different levels where we do different smex positions
is the town cute and funny
yeah is the town cute and funny in Final Fantasy
um
different locations full changing room no
oh do you know how gross pool changing rooms are come on
choose a better location um oh I killed one of them
um
shut up and take my money no I don't I don't make I don't make a game
already have one game coming out soon hopefully
hopefully
um
like the airplane bathroom you guys are gross you choose the grossest
place to to frickin I killed them
sorry if you hear fart sounds it's my chair
behind the home depot
badge discovered rookie pet owner badge earned a new pet owner
um pet owner princess nacho
what what is princess nacho oh my god she's so cute is
she my pet
she's so cute and her name is princess nacho
uh it means we're in big bro's room the living room the laundry room the
kitchen the porch okay that's okay those are acceptable I guess
so cute may I recommend a very obscure game that I played a lot of times I
guess if you want I'm the likelihood of me playing it is
low but if you want to recommend it
but notice that the dark magic that was previously jokling this
story seems to have abated why do they use big words like abated in this game
do you think I know what abated means I'm a I'm a child here
sorry I'm not a child I'm an adult I'm an adult I'm an adult I'm an adult
I don't know what abated means though these butterflies
oh
oh there's butterflies that's so pretty
so
to piss off kids but it's it's a game for kids why would you want to piss them off
why doesn't chat want to answer me chat is there anyone else playing in this
lobby with me or no
okay just walk by me in final fantasy 14 most of the towns aren't super cute but
the most visited place in the game is a very cute casino called the gold
saucer there are so many things to earn in games to
play there but I want a game where all the
towns are cute I got ghosted by chat no one wants to
answer me
chat please who do I talk to this one
I never played maple story either I really I really don't have a lot of
childhood games and I'm not really interested in the old
ones either oh wait but thank you for the
ten dollars but yeah I want to I want a game where all of the places are cute
you know
Amy's mouth felt your kicks in a little late compared to her mouth
sometimes it does
you should take it to the library in the commons harold auguston will know what
to do with it what level am I in this game
how do I know
I'm feeling a little nauseous right now and I don't know why
where's my level
can someone help me see my level see on level four didn't someone say that
after level five it's like paywalled have you eaten today
yes I literally ate at the start getting too hot
that's very possible I am very hot right now
okay well let's um
I don't know I'll try playing a little more
drink your wawa I am feel free to rest
oh I wanted to get to level five maybe you're overdressed
I'm never overdressed for streams
preggers from the beach oh my god you think someone
in the water I'm kidding
you think you think the water that I went in was contaminated
it's paywalled on the on two of the big three streets and beyond that oh okay
feel free to rub your tummy and clap your feet together like a baby
oh wait I'm not rubbing my tongue are you gay you hear that why are you acting so
gay something original tipped five dollars abated means lessened
but is only used for negative or bad things oh thank you thank you for the
five dollars and thank you for explaining
well okay well bye chat
I can't make emojis oh I can bye chat
I'll miss you I'll miss you guys
okay
I'm gonna switch to just chatting
and then I'm gonna lean back a little bit
oh give me a second
I would not take care of a whale baby no I would actually not take care of any
baby because I don't want babies
we love you even though your hair looks like a bird's nest right now on my model
it doesn't in the game maybe because it's ugly
huh I saw the shirt about your voice figured I would pop it and say hello
uh
welcome welcome to any new people thank you for watching the short I suppose
I feel a little icky hold on
no babies a woman after my own heart no babies no babies do I still have the
game what are you playing I do let me leave the game
exit here we go
those that was a good walk down memory lane
um
I hope you feel better I think I will I think I just need to
I don't know probably end stream and turn on my ac and take a shower
oh I don't know why why this why that happened
usually this doesn't happen I'm usually good I'm not a fragile being
usually mentally fragile yes physically I'm usually good though
I wanted to spend more time with you though
how was the beach it was all right I don't know the the food was
uh gross though thank you for becoming a pin pal
I do got those former jeans
for babies are okay of course for babies are always okay
is a zero streaming today
mm-hmm thank you for becoming a member I slept through most of the stream
welcome back
we can wait for you a little in me we'll always be waiting for you to recover
oh shit
hmm you're the last wheeler stream today thank you thank you
wheeler moderator for um hiding that um
am I really oh people wait is a zero not streaming this week
oh she's
wait what
oh she's offline for a good chunk of the week
thank you for becoming a pin pal getting real close to 40k
yeah not really not really but kind of kind of a little bit sort of I don't know
kind of when we're at 49 I'll say we're close
the zero is working on donutungles I noticed I saw that on her schedule
huh let me look up some girlies that I haven't followed yet but I need to
like Victoria and the other special late girls you guys should go support
um you guys should go support special uh special light
en they're really cool girls and also they fuck with us which I appreciate
um unfortunately it does not appear like any special late girl is online though
frick
you keep saying this and you know what happens nothing happens
I will not have a special stream for 69k
okay um you know what frick it I'm not gonna rate anyone today yep I'm not gonna rate anyone
I'm gonna leave you all alone with no one to watch and I'm gonna leave you missing me
because I'm gone sorry
um but yeah I'll see you tomorrow we'll be playing um kill it with fire with um
um Fuyo and
juna from idol um
you should go watch my newest ASMR
and I don't know I'm kind of brain dead I don't know look out for a song cover soon I guess
and don't have high expectations and that's all I can say but sis what about the voices the voices
will you'll have to deal with them you'll have to deal with them all alone now they're coming back
the voices are coming back um yeah there's that stream on Friday um I might have to cancel it
I really am not sure I'm going to try not to cancel the brosley stream
but I might have to um but we'll see um
yeah we'll see we'll see we'll see I'll try not to okay bye see you tomorrow love you pookie
oh
Wait, hold on guys wait before you go I just saw that that V that is doing their their
outfit reveals so I'm gonna send you most of me I'm gonna send you most of me stream
I didn't know you should go watch their outfit reveals for their new outfits oh go watch that
that's really cool go support V did it pin pin how do I pin pin okay there go watch them
that's really cool I'll probably be watching that okay but you don't have to say emmy raid though
because I won't be I won't I won't be um I won't be typing in stream but that's really cool so you
should go support them okay bye